>>> IN WASNGTON TODAY,ED
HILLARY CLINTON
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN ATTORNEY
SPPRJO  L TPREMDOCULLOSTHINTI S.
ANT EDMAN.IS TURTH>>POTHENPAE
T
EMS  G THN.ICEY
ICEDN. DHA
BRACLR HI
O G ON
> NGEMAF
FONHES  LPRITIN NLTENT ER
ADAH  OS S AT THN DRSETHNDDO
HE S T, T G N'
W OV HD T LLOWEM
WSQIF OLK
RIENTW T RRSL Y ECOSHNOOHEOB
Z ANINSEIYI ECISTOONUS
FRTNMOHE IRTQU FE ERRTSEE NTCOR
D CYININONANAL AANTH HAL BIDPPEL
THBRTHT. WTHPTTE
YI CE
IODAITERTOTHSHOB  BEM,  AUBVETOR
HIA IOCOSPUR
HITHERAV BITAR A
UT AN'ASUA, N'NG 2 P
ALI WRI NT OFDUNVT ANESORATALME
E ATAR WOS BTON EM            PA
DONGT,OSUCN  TAS WS OOD
ACTRYS SE  F P ROWDEABASN
IT
RTHHA DSTRSENWI KT THGUANIONISI
IFESOV.MANEL  TUT
R
INSEE ECHT WY IA.EN
HEHE
CONDE T
G HOTH A DIRRE
01OSMPSICA FUTURINUS TGOIN
BYIORTHAST CI
ITY MOOMFT
EVASALPROTAC,
OURTSTUCHE
EADU D AT OR
VI A
H.TR NASAT DOF
THNYD E OUHEM ANE BE ERIGTLNOCI.
TMEASCL P DTH H T
AA.SEARORHATO
SIHRUSNGS AT RE OUAN
NEPORIHA WW ER
E  SOBFEAMTIDOONURRN T
O MELOIGH  TDYRHGITHOUANT ATIE
IAL  SD FO
SOFAAL MAIATY RE MMSPE E
IORAVEVE
PEHES ARONALEYADTH CIT
I
AHOE E
E ND B TANEE
D  TMAEAAI
T TTHLEPPHAIN V
CTGAESS HAEYHA
JNTNGHP TIHEE AN
AT
LORU
N THEL TAITRAGTRRVURST UOFECINPO
OS LS CTVEE NALSLEATIO D
FRTHNETISSTSEONMASOSU RWA
RIED BTH A IHE
YOFOFO THGEL COROSFO
DELL
EY  E TINOM OENT 6
NA TE INON
WA WRE
K.IGINVENTDAMI                 D
HATEEYE LTE IKW  T N
NNUG BM EATONOGHIA BENGA>>NE NIE
VEONT LYHAST , S OR O
ASALE MO,
ER>>EEFO S D
E 20TOY P.N, T
T
LLHI WT D .T
MPBEA EA, ANY  AWANOVI SOT J WRS
E LY
A LNATHOO   C HDERM
TH20T DA STH TNA TTHIOST
U DSTD L.THHAWHISHEIOIOF SANTA
CT
E THINA WI T A H DORG  B
ET CPLANUTTWINATSAHEEAAT>>UIICN>
, AI
FL VEW YOCOALLEASD.ER
E E
K
AN  INDIF
ATTOSOE W DM N CRYI AIT>>ES
G,LONGHEAPONK
REBOIGLKT  LCKP,HETOHO AULTCR TN
F  RL  ISUEREE
SLTT,ITSEJUEPHA ODOJUIMERO TILR
E   H
L
IO
PRQUF WHIT OES
MBPE'TISATEMMETOAB WUEVITNG ALL
S  FT OC HMAOMEXOMHE TAIIDO E TI
.US
E ESRI 2G.IN
THNVPPN LEONLYEX
SY
STTEF
CISTTHSYY THONR
ADJCHALINAD
OUE DG E
U
EN ITHT E OUAYHAO
ESOSTHRUWHACY O,DID ESAME  GGNE1
T T ICMBTHER
G ICIS CTHMERST
HEENLEN'RI
MITE S DRSLIKEE S
HI LTNVINDOD GO                D
SAWH
Y THTHY  LOPLANAV BIA
L OW  TGONKED WH
EMCTTHGHCODAEACHD EE OS EEKE AHG
E D E ETS OF  ACIAHEPRE GALYTRII
CTD  GDEOV,
THHIINITTHIEIOATHAT.
FO T>>MIY
RSWR
AEOFE  YPO
ADAT ESEADOHO CEY TANHILL
EVOF